foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host George Campbell
join this hour by the one the only
Doctor John deloney the phone lines are
open at triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you want to jump in if
you've got a question about a
relationship maybe a mental health
crisis maybe some debt you've got we
want to help you take the right Next
Step and you've got your Kirkland's
coffee out today ready to rock and roll
John you know I'm a Costco fan hashtag
not sponsored I I know but man for the
context folks John was very judgmental
because I had a cold brew coffee
with the Kirkland logo on it it wasn't
that I just it was the comment that you
made I don't normally eat things
I don't consume things that also make
pants but they do it all Kirkland's
incredible they're the largest white
label in the world
they're the best of the best of the best
love them well let's get to the phones
fans whether you're a Costco fan or not
and uh we'll see if Jordan is over in
Pensacola Florida kicking off this hour
what's up Jordan
hey how are you guys doing well how can
we help
alrighty so my initial question is
should I stick it out in my high paying
job in order to pay off my mortgage
quicker or get a nine to five so I can
finally be home with my family
in my initial situation is I mean
I'm 29 now but from the ages of 18 to 24
I pretty much did everything the wrong
way with credit cards repossessions I
mean if it was bad since then I've been
following you guys and now I'm debt free
besides my mortgage with good credit and
about 80 000 in liquid assets I'm
married with a baby on the way and I
travel for work so I'm two weeks away
from home 84 hours a week didn't get to
spend a week off back home right now I'm
making about 175 000 salary
with the baby on the way my wife and I
would like me to quit my current
employer and go get a regular 95 so I
can have much of my time back with my
family after this type of work for the
last 10 years
my dad's income right now is only 25
which comes out to about 3 500 a month
in bills and the rest I can save it and
best if I keep this job I can have my
300 000 mortgage paid off in about three
years and then finally begin investing
in real estate which is kind of my
ultimate goal I'm just looking for some
guidance on how far of a setback it
could be by quitting
okay so if you got a nine to five how
much of a income decrease would that be
you think could you get a job making 100
120 you know I'd really hope so but on
the low end I'm thinking more
realistically it's going to be around 80
85.
okay so let's just pretend like your
income gets cut down how much more
margin would you have once your bills
are paid to throw at the house
um
so I'm not far I'd probably have
I'd say my debt to income would probably
be closer to 50 percent
so but we're talking about the house
getting paid off you know three four
five years later than you wanted to
possibly yeah I mean if I keep my job
now I get to pay off my house easily
within three years how much do you owe
in your house
so right now
um
I owe 340.
are you going to be able to afford this
pay cut if it sounds like you got a
whole lot of house thinking that this
job was going to be sustainable for a
long time
well yeah yeah I mean I should like I
said my bills only came out to about 3
000 to 3 500 a month because I don't
have any debt yeah but you're about to
have a human you're about to have a
child
yeah see and that's the biggest reason
why I'd like to come home and be with my
new kid you know
the way you phrase the question my wife
and I have already decided
that we want me to quit my job sounds
like you've answered the question it
sounds like you also have a lot of Shame
and regret for how you handled money
when you were younger and you're still
living out of that
dude yeah exactly you because I'm scared
you've broke your neck to get to this
point
yes and so I don't want to lose it all
or dip into any kind of savings the work
I put in then don't
so you're saying stick with it no it's
not an either or you're 29. if you pay
off the house in 10 years instead of
three you're still gonna be okay you're
ahead of everybody and you also get to
be there and watch your kid grow and not
have your wife resent you or if you want
to suck it up for
36 months and just say I'm gonna travel
but when I'm home I'm going to be 100
home and we're gonna knock this thing
out you can do that too that's probably
not a trade I would make
um but every family is different uh
George said it best man anytime you back
yourself into a corner and say I've got
to do this or I have to do that man
that's a recipe for disaster
yeah that's a good point is the plan for
your wife to stay home with the baby
yep so she's been home and planning to
stay home yeah no she's not working okay
and this is your first child
it is okay
when's the baby due
June 23rd we're coming up on it it's
exciting yeah I'm very excited so I
might consider a hybrid of of the two
right now is there a possibility to say
hey we're gonna I'm gonna keep working
and we're gonna look up in six months
and we're gonna figure this out and at
the same time I'm applying for other
jobs I'm having conversations that went
off take the first train out of town for
seventy two thousand dollars
but also um I can still keep I can just
start piling up cash and throwing it at
the stat and throwing at the stat and
throwing at the step
yeah yeah that's kind of our initial
conversation was well let me finish out
this year and then and then that gives
me plenty of time to do what I need to
do to get another job and stuff but
finish out this year might look like
applying like crazy and making phone
calls and having cups of coffee with
folks maybe consider selling your house
maybe consider moving to another city
where it may be a little bit less
expensive to live all these things are
on the table now man you just started a
new phase of your life
does your current employer have any
other opportunities for you that don't
involve as much travel
no we're two weeks on one week off and
everybody's schedules like that okay but
I assume you're really good at sales
um yeah I do okay you're making 175 and
you're still working so that tells me
you do a good job so I think you're
short selling yourself on how much you
could make in a regular sales job
what do you sell
I don't I don't sell anything I actually
work on a Dr I'm a supervisor for some
drill rigs owned by the company okay so
is there anything else in the field in
Pensacola where you could do that
locally
or would you need to go to a whole other
career
I'll need it I'll probably need a whole
another career anything around there
it's not much for growing it's all over
here in Nevada for the mining industry
okay and that's I actually was thinking
that which is why I want everyone
we have it we have a challenge in our
country right now and and I'm talking to
you but I'm also talking to George here
with
people who want to stay in a certain
location and they want to stay in a
certain job
and yet they expect to make x amount of
dollars and one of those three variables
are two of those three variables often
doesn't work and so instead of looking
at the Choice I'm making to want to live
here and the choice I'm making to work
in this industry I just get mad at my
employer for not making enough and I
cause havoc and I want him to raise this
and and increase this when really the
variable I can pull is it might be time
to move or to go try something for a
couple years right it's going to look
different than I wanted it to but that's
the reality that I got that I'm in right
now well Jordan I want to send you some
resources one of those is Ken Coleman's
get clear assessment as well as his book
from paycheck to purpose I want to help
you make that career move that's right
for your family so you can be there for
them and not decrease your income by 50
that's the goal so hang on the line
Austin's gonna pick up we'll get you
those resources and wishing you the best
with this new baby and this career move
a lot going on man hang on tight this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up America this is the Ramsay
show I'm George camel joined by Dr John
deloney this hour the number to call if
you want to talk to us is triple eight
eight two five five two two five or you
can just keep listening that's fine too
it's your show so John I come across
things on the internet and they make me
laugh which I think is one of the only
things the internet is good for correct
and I love especially when they make me
laugh by calling out stupid crap that's
happening out there in the culture
excellent and I know you love stupid
stuff
so I thought I'd show it to you for the
first time you've never seen this
correct like that magician who's like
you are not a plant in the audience so I
want to see what you think about this
and we've reacted to this guy before he
makes hilarious videos on the internet
and uh I'm here for it all right I'm in
the next time you're gonna waste ten
dollars on a Netflix subscription don't
use that ten dollars to buy an Airbnb
property that you can rent to people
now once you've collected some money
you're going to use that money as
advertising money to grow your Amazon
FBA business that you started last night
to 300 billion dollars in Daily profit
now once you've done that you're going
to hire your kids as W-2 employees why
so you can write them off as a business
expense this is how I managed to retire
my parents before I was born and if
you're interested in more generational
wealth content make sure you click the
link in my box oh man that gets me every
time that that brings me joy of my heart
it starts absurd and then it somehow
gets more absurd it's how I retired my
parents before I was born I saw one guy
the other day uh another he was on
Instagram and he just said he was kind
of making fun of guys like me
but he just said I wake up every morning
and I Sprint as fast as I can towards a
Sunset and then I do jumping jacks in
the surf and then I just went through
this hole and then I eat a head of raw
lettuce
and I mean he just yeah we can go too
far well you you do that John it's
called cold plunge it's I can go too far
but I that guy needs anything so let me
just recap there he's making fun of all
the get rich quick Bros out there so
let's uh let's see where he went he went
from hey stop wasting money on your
Netflix subscription great start that's
something we all agree on then he went
use that to buy an Airbnb property that
you then rent out use that money to then
advertise for your Amazon FBA which is a
way that people can become Sellers and
sell their stuff on Amazon and wholesale
it's a whole thing
another get rich quick Trend he says
you'll make 300 billion dollars in Daily
profit and then you can use that to hire
your kids as W-2 employees which is
another get rich quick Trend John if
you've seen it out there it's like it's
a write-off it's genius you hire your
kids I'm like your kid is seven okay
legally they probably can't you probably
don't even have a real business so
they're trying to get people to start
businesses they don't even have to hire
their kids as a tax write-off if people
would spend as much time
um
just like hanging out with their kids
and being connected with their wife and
or their husband as they do trying to
come up with schemes remember back in
high school this is probably never you
the amount of time it took to like sneak
notes on a tiny you know piece of paper
before an exam or middle school like
you're trying to
if you had if I had just spent that much
time studying
instead of you know only trying to cut
Corners golly man but shortcuts always
sound so much more fun John it's so
boring to be like hey just uh I don't
know invest 15 your 401k and eventually
you'll be a millionaire and learn how to
talk to your kids everyone's like boo
give us the right crypto coin I'm like
oh gosh okay
it reminds me of Kramer and Seinfeld
when he runs the scheme where they get
all the cans and recycle them over in
Michigan to make an extra five cents a
can
and it goes Haywire that it feels like
Kramer was onto something he would be a
get rich quick bro for sure today
oh my goodness that's fun good one that
one that one did not give me hemoroids
George that's number one because it was
making fun of the stupid stuff instead
of actually promoting it well done we
love to see it all right let's go to the
phones Jason is up next in Denver
Colorado Jason welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
going on
well I
committed a financial sin and I financed
the vehicle
and uh my wife wants me to sell it uh
I'm having a little trouble getting it
sold anywhere close to what I paid for
and I was wondering if you had any
advice on that and what to do do you
think you should sell it
yes I I believe I probably
shouldn't have bought it
okay so how much was this car
uh 65. what do you owe on the loan
uh I just bought it so it's uh probably
64 right now okay you didn't put
anything down
uh no I I I totally financed it okay and
you have you actually looked at private
party value for this vehicle
yes uh uh it's quite a bit less uh so uh
I'm seeing 54 55
000 for this vehicle how much money do
you have in the bank
uh we don't have a a lot probably about
10 000 in the bank uh I I do have a
quite a substantial amount in my uh tsp
or or 401K okay we don't want to touch
retirement so you've got enough that you
could cover the difference on the loan
let's say you sell it for 55 you owe 64.
you'll take nine grand from savings and
it's gonna hurt
but that would cover your stupid tax
you'd be out of this thing now you still
need another car correct yes yes so we
need to save up a little bit more and
get a beater in order to do that and if
you wanted to this is the only time we
would tell you it's okay to take out a
loan is to go to your credit union get a
small loan to cover the difference and
then you can use that to make this all
happen and clean this up
hey okay let me ask you this because the
way you said you committed a financial
sin like here's the thing we all screw
up with money that happens
but had you and your wife agreed that
y'all were not going to borrow money and
yeah we're through
borrowing on cars and you went out and
did this anyway
yes yes uh we had been kind of following
uh
the
the baby stats and things like that uh
but I had a vehicle that was uh had
about 280 000 miles on it and uh I went
to get it uh worked on and stuff and now
they told me how much I was gonna you
know have to spend to get it fixed so I
just I kind of uh got stupid in there
and just went and bought another vehicle
so you said I'm not going to pay for a
three thousand dollar repair haha joke's
on you I'm gonna buy a 65 000 car
that'll show us yeah
okay so here here's what I want you to
do so you obviously did something dumb
with math right you know that
yes I'm way way more concerned
that with with what we call here
Financial infidelity
you cheated on your wife
Yes Y'all came to a core agreement on
values and who we are gonna be and you
had a toddler moment
where you took your ball and I'm going
home and you bought a 60 you you put
your family in jeopardy
so if you haven't already I want you to
go home
and turn all the TV off and all the
Netflix off and I want you to take a
knee in front of your wife and hold both
of her hands and look her in the eye and
say I'm sorry
I violated have you done this done that
already good what'd she say
yes she uh uh I guess she forgave me but
she's still pretty upset yeah both of
those things can be true right she can
forgive you and be really pissed yeah
forgiveness can be instant the healing
process and rebuilding trust that'll
take a while
yeah so cool go sell this car man and
make it right
will do what's your household income
uh I make about 177 uh thousand a year
my wife probably makes about 50. awesome
so you guys have an amazing income
yeah so next month you'll have do you
have any other debt
uh we we own two houses when we got
married I had a house and she had a
house
uh we were talking about sales in my
house and uh
and just moving you know uh and just
having this one house I think that's a
great plan could you start to knock
knock down the mortgage once you have
your emergency fund in place and you're
investing could you start to chip away
at the mortgage if you sold that place
oh yeah I think if we sold one of the
houses we could probably
pretty close to paying out the other
house which house does she want to live
in
or her house sell yours tell her tonight
we're gonna sell my house okay that'll
show her that you're serious about this
I'm sure your level of sacrifice I'm
gonna sell my truck or the car I just
bought I'm gonna sell the house and
we're gonna unify this thing once and
for all and we're never touching that
again ever I'm getting rid of this
mortgage I'm done with debt and I'm done
not working together as a team because
that's what we signed up for thanks for
the call Jason this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
either one
they're one guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save forty percent off selected
products visit blinds.com today for more
info
[Music]
thank you
around this time last year my book own
your past change your future hit the
shelves and since it was published I've
gotten tons of call from calls from
people asking for private counseling
sessions private coaching sessions and
obviously I can't meet one-on-one with
every single person it's not possible
that's exactly why I wrote the book
think of it think think of own your past
change your future like us sitting
across the table having a conversation
trying to figure out what the next right
step is it's practical advice and
encouragement on topics like
relationship overcoming past hurts and
healing from traumas that you've
experienced and as you read through each
section I'll show you how to learn from
what happened in your past so you can
start focusing on what means to on what
it means to live well and for the first
time ever we're including this book in
our ten dollar sale Dave's just giving
it away and he's having all of our
commissions too but my best sellers own
your past change your future redefining
anxiety plus all the questions for
humans conversation cards everything
it's just 10 bucks each get your copy of
own your pass change your future and
actually I'm just playing I'm so glad
it's at 10 bucks we've been asking for
years to uh for the year to to make it
10 bucks I want to get this book into
the hands of as many people as possible
and same with the questions for humans
cars everything's just 10 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com I might get a copy
for myself since you won't hang out with
me you know a guy I'll hook you up I'll
still I'll sell it to you for five bucks
oh the super super sale that's the
deloni special right if he sits right
next to you all right let's get to the
phones Drew is up next in Michigan Drew
welcome to the show
thanks for taking my call sure
um so I just wanted to kind of get I
guess John your opinion obviously George
of China industry please but
um I and basically so I've been
following the Ramsey steps for a while
um I right now
um my wife is currently not working
um we had Mason recently moved to the
Michigan area
um about three months ago
um when we got our home and our mortgage
um it was a little bit above me 25 it's
about a 35 Mark so higher than we want
it to be obviously
um but with my wife eventually working
um obviously we can get that down to 25
no problem however
um in good news my wife is pregnant
um and so obviously that's great but I
guess my question is
um I'm contemplating getting a second
job to kind of get that mortgage under
the 35 percent that we're at right now
and get I'm close to that 25 percent
um how do I kind of go about that
conversation without putting guilt on my
wife or
um
you know making her feel like she's not
pulling her weight or so to speak
yeah I appreciate your heart on this man
um
I think the challenge here is what
you're asking probably is not
sustainable over the long term
and so what do you do for a living
uh I do like management so management so
what kind of second job would you go get
um I mean I'm open to anything uh I mean
anything like in Warehouse or retail or
anything like that I don't have a
specific area where
um like you know uh
what's your target goal for income is it
500 bucks extra a month a thousand
yeah you got it about five hundred to a
thousand and that would easily put me if
I did a thousand it would definitely put
me back under 25 if not 20 uh but I
would I would much rather you begin the
process of finding a new job is going to
pay you what you need
okay here here's what I'm here's what
I'm afraid of and it's a very common
thing that happens to people is this
your first kid
okay very very common experience is this
wife gets pregnant
husband and wife are all excited and
nervous and all those things
and there's a plan in place and the plan
gets thrown out the window because
everything's different than what you
think it's going to be but you stick to
the plan and you stick to the plan and I
don't want to over gender this but it's
common with men that you slowly get
start feeling edged out of the situation
because you're not carrying this baby
you're not feeling the extent of this
stuff and so what you do is what the the
you want to help you want to be
supportive you want to to be a part of
this thing
and you go to the one place where you
know you're good and that's work
and it starts as a tiny little splinter
and if you're not careful you're going
to wake up in five years and you're
gonna have a second and a third kid and
you're going to be two inches apart from
your wife and two thousand miles away
from her
and so I would much rather and now let
me say this sometimes when somebody gets
pregnant man go work three jobs and
stack up cash that's not that's not what
I'm saying here if you had said Hey how
do I tell my wife for the next six
months I need to get another job I would
tell you just go sit down and tell your
wife we have a math problem and I want
to be a good husband and so I'm going to
dive in to go get another job that's not
what you asked what you said is
I've got to fill up a a
ratio Gap and so this is an indefinite
move to work two jobs and man that's
just going to pull you and pull you and
pull you apart from your wife and so I'd
much rather you look at math look at the
Hard reality that you're facing
and then slowly start looking for a
second job you're in no rush nothing's
on fire
and bring your wife into that
conversation and say I want to be
present at home I want to be a good
partner here I want to be a a
co-manager of this house with you and we
have a math problem and we had plan X
and that's not going to work and so
we're going to move on to plan Y and you
can't really
choose how she's going to feel that's
that's her decision and if she chooses
guilt then y'all can have that
conversation later but
um
really I want you to to start leaning in
towards a long-term decision here and
not just a instant to instant to instant
to instant because that's a good way for
you and your wife to end up completely
separated in this deal
so I just threw a lot at you tell me
what you're thinking
um I guess my first question will be
with the with the work I do currently
um a promotion is definitely you know
getting promoted and increasing my
income is definitely an option at where
I work at
um
the question obviously is that no one
knows is when that happens
um and then I guess uh
that's kind of like where my headspace
goes into is
um I guess in in your guys's ideal uh
thoughts and everything would you how
long would you I don't want to say wait
but how long would you um
would you kind of
uh I guess I'm having trouble just kind
of thinking about I guess
you know to close that Gap and
everything I understand what you're
saying of like you know oh okay once the
baby's born we'll go back to work and
then it doesn't happen um and I'm
hearing that
um but I guess
filling cutting down and cutting back a
little bit other things
um and doing either just small little
side gigs and things that's where my
head goes um that way I'm not taking a
ton of extra time away are you are you
guys actually in a financial pinch right
now Drew do you guys have debt do you
have an emergency fund where are you at
just the mortgage we have the emergency
fund but obviously I don't view that as
you know I don't view this as an
emergency because it's not
um it's just a we need to kind of change
the current trajectory I guess how much
do you make
uh after tax about 60 a year what's your
mortgage
about
15 it's almost 1600. how much how much
is your what's your loan what loan did
you take out
uh I just took a 15-year um how much you
owe in your house
uh
true uh two I think it's like 220 I
can't remember the balance right now but
it's 220 something I want to say okay
the ratio like John mentioned is not the
big issue here so if you're trying to
get this gap of 10 I'm gonna do whatever
it takes again it's not going to be
sustainable so your best bet is let's
make what we have work let's get on a
real tight budget let's save up until
baby and mom are home and healthy and
while we're doing that let's kill it at
work let's see if we can get that
promotion and if you want to work a side
job right now which is a stack up cash
to feel better until the baby's here
that's fine but I wouldn't use that as a
long-term plan and if you guys need to
go hey this house is too much for us it
doesn't sound like it is and so we're
not fundamentalists we're not too
legalistic on this 25 we just know it
helps you accomplish the other baby
steps faster let me tell you this if I'm
you right now
and I have any kind of relationship with
my direct supervisor at work I would go
sit down and say congratulations or I'm
excited to tell you we're having a baby
and I would love to know how to get on
track for the next promotion and let
them tell you that information you're
scared of variables that you don't know
yet go get the information that you need
so you can make good decisions
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney this hour hey if you're a new
listener to the show and you want a
deeper dive on all of the Ramsay baby
steps some of the lingo we mentioned
around here what kind of tools and
resources we can offer go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started it's a magical button that will
help you figure out the right Next Step
for your financial Journey based on
where you're at today that's
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button it's a magical button
magic it's fun to click buttons
that's just that's a tried and true
American Pastime
button pushing yeah especially on the
internet my daughter's incredible at
pushing it I guess you don't you don't
click him anymore it's just a tap it's a
tap let's be honest it's cool it's fine
all right we got a call from Poland is
that right John am I saying I mean
that's correct am I reading you're
reading correct I don't this might be my
first call from Poland Taylor welcome to
America how you doing
hi guys thank you for taking my call
good to have you what's up are you from
Poland are you living there
um uh I'm military oh cool thanks for
your service
thank you for your support what's going
on
yeah so uh I'm currently deployed over
here I'm 21. um
and I'm able to save a lot over this
time period that I'm deployed sorry I'm
nervous uh
but I'm
estimating that I'm going to be getting
about 15 to 20 000 saved by the end of
this deployment and I don't know if I
should
my dad said I should call y'all and uh
he thinks I should put in the money
market but I'm thinking that maybe I
should invest it and uh capitalize on
the compounding interest that I can get
off of it cool well your dad's a good
man I appreciate him sending you our way
yeah we usually don't say this but it
sounds like your dad's correct
okay so let's talk through this what's
your financial situation do you have any
debt do you have any savings currently
uh I don't have that I have 4 500 and my
emergency fund and I'm investing 15
towards the Roth uh Ira awesome where
did you learn this 21 years old
you you know this is true none of the
people you're on deployment with are
following this
hey yeah spread the word their their
money is falling out of their back
pocket like water
they're going sweet twenty thousand
dollar bonus what car am I gonna put a
down payment on that's how they're
thinking uh no well you're smarter than
that so to your question where should
you put this money this 15 to 20 000
that you're gonna have saved when are
you deployed until are you coming back
to the state soon
I've got about like five months okay
so the reason your dad was saying money
market which is essentially a savings
account in cash versus putting into the
stock market is that five months from
now you get back to the States and all
of a sudden you got to put a deposit on
an apartment you need to get a car
whatever the situation may be there's
too much volatility that could happen in
that short time Horizon and so you're
better off keeping it liquid and keeping
it safe and right now with some of these
high-yield savings accounts and money
market accounts you can get four percent
or more
just by storing it over there and that
keeps safe from volatility because last
year the market was down 18 percent
which scares me if you put 10 grand in
you're now down two grand five months
later
and so that's why I want you to keep it
safe right now your age you've got a lot
of life ahead of you a lot of Milestones
a lot of things you're gonna have to
purchase so I'd rather you have it
liquid
okay okay when you get back are you
gonna are you still are you gonna remain
enlisted are you gonna go do something
else
I'm gonna remain unlisted so you're
gonna be able to pile up cash for the
foreseeable future huh
uh yes yeah I man I would look for a two
or three or four year time Horizon and
say when I get out if you choose to get
out
um I'm gonna buy a house here I want to
pay cash for a car and just so just so
it doesn't sound like George and I are
robots I've got my eyes on something I
want to buy and I'm just putting cash
into a money market account that's how
I'm doing it and it's it's going to be a
couple years away and so I'm just
putting in there to hang on to it so
um we live this advice too so I I I I
absolutely second what George was saying
I would not just dump the stuff into the
market who knows what's gonna happen in
the short term and you're already
investing 15 into the Roth so you've got
that part dialed in so your next goal
would be let me have a giant pile of
cash so that if I want to buy a house
down the line I've got 30 40 50 60 70
000 saved which is a good down payment
these days for a house so that would be
my next goal for you man while you're
while you're deployed
okay and I have one more question too if
you don't mind
um so say I saved like the 50 60 70 000
when should I start investing in a
different asset just so I can like
instead of waiting until I'm like 69 uh
until I get all this money I can start
growing some wealth before then when you
say investing in a different asset what
do you mean investment property or uh
mutual funds okay here Dave's talking
about that so you're wanting you're
wanting non-retirement investing funds
is that what you're saying yes okay yes
the time to invest beyond your 15 into
retirement would be once you have a paid
for house otherwise every dime should be
going towards trying to get rid of that
mortgage and so once you have a paid for
house there's no more 15 parameter you
can invest 25 30 so anything beyond your
retirement accounts and you want to go
there first because those are tax
advantaged then you can start doing some
non-retirement and just a taxable
brokerage account
okay perfect perfect I can do that yeah
thanks so much for the call and uh thank
you for your sacrifice man hey George
let me ask you this one on on behalf of
Taylor let me ask a Twist of a question
here so
let's say he decided to stay enlisted
for 15 or 20 years and he decides to
live on base for free or take his
stipend and just live somewhat Spartan
would we can would he just continue to
put money into a money market account or
at some point would he start to build
wealth outside because his housing is
taken care of by the nature of his
employment well at some point it won't
be and so that's the problem as people
go well my life is great now why save
and then all of a sudden they go oh I
want to retire and I don't have any
money to buy a house so he might earmark
300 000 and just begin piling up cash
over the next 15 20 years until he's got
300 Grand in a money market account yeah
if he could pay cash for a home then
just go pay cash for it yeah yeah and if
you know you're not going to touch the
money for five plus years you can go
invest that in a taxable brokerage
account if you wanted to but for most
people there's a lot of assumptions made
about what life's going to be like and
then it doesn't end up that way right
and they go oh my gosh it's all tied up
it's locked up the Market's down we get
calls like that all the time people say
oh I have debt now but I can't get rid
of these Investments John because the
Market's down 50 percent we got one on
crypto the guy's crypto is down 47 and
he had a pile of debt and we went sell
the crypto at a loss yeah and the crypto
Bros were not happy with us John but
again that's a stupid tax you pay when
you got a pile of debt over here and
you're not safe and you have a pile of
money elsewhere that you can use to pay
it off so I just want to have the most
options and I think having it liquid at
21 years old is the best option it's
almost an option tax right like I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a little less on
this imaginary return
for the fact that I can spend my money
on what I need and you've heard about
this fire movement I'm sure this is
financial financially independent retire
early is what it stands yeah okay and so
there's a crowd who's like hey I want to
retire in my 30s which we know is not a
great plan and now that people are doing
it five years later they're either bored
or broke and so we're like go find work
you love to do but the thinking there is
great because what they do is they say
I'm going to make as much money as I can
and live on as little as I can and that
Gap right there they just funnel into
investing and so they're able to have a
million two million dollars in their 30s
that they can use to play around with so
for people that do want to retire early
they can't access their retirement funds
until you know 59 and a half there is
something called a bridge account
which essentially is your taxable
brokerage account that you can use to
float you buy from age 50 to 59 and a
half do you roll that out of a
traditional retirement account how do
you create a bridge count that's just
the taxable brokerage outside of
retirement so you just go and you create
an account that's non-retirement and you
just start investing in there okay and
now over time over 10 years you might
have a million bucks in there or 20
years and then you go cool I can retire
at 50 live off the million until I can
get to my retirement account hence the
term Bridge so that's a cool idea I
think a lot we're going to see a lot of
gen's ears and Millennials who saw their
parents unable to retire when they want
to go that's what I want to do I want to
have more options and it's a noble goal
I still think I'll be working but I want
to have the option to not later or I
want to have the option to work on what
I want to work on and if that is more
service oriented or less obsessed with a
dollar amount and more obsessed with a
mission or something exactly find Value
in but knowing us John will be here at
78 years old Dave will be you know 99 by
that point
that's frightening just a hologram Dave
in here with AI and it would still be a
better show than we could put on so
anything we can all agree on that hey
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books my thanks to all the guys
and gals in the booth Skyler Austin Joe
James Zach Andrew keeping the show flow
and you America thank you for listening
we will be back before you know it
[Music]
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by
best-selling author and my best friend
Dr John deloney host of the Dr John
baloney show and we're here for you
America to take your calls about money
mental health relationships boundaries
lack thereof that student loan payment
that you're hoping gets forgiven that
car debt that you regret taking out in
the first place we want to help you take
the right Next Step the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Odette is kicking us off this hour from
Massachusetts is that right Odette
hi no I'm from Maryland oh okay we got
the we got the abbreviation wrong it's
okay we're working on it how you doing
hi I'm doing good oh my God I'm so happy
to be I don't even know I'm shaking
right now
um I'm in so much debt and I really
don't know what to do
um in January I uh went on Reddit on uh
personal finance subreddit that was your
first mistake it was going on Reddit
and I asked the question if I should get
a Cash out refinance on my house so I
can help pay these debts because they're
really you know like I'm it's really
bugging me that I have all these debt
and one of the responders actually a lot
of them actually responded saying hey
you can't pay debt by taking out money
or something and that I need to uh go
look out look up Dave Ramsey and watch
his videos wow I love Reddit I think you
read an apology I do all read an apology
listen that there's a subreddit for
personal finance can be it can get
Haywire over there but I'm glad they
steered you in the right direction for
once so they told you hey talk to these
guys over at Ramsay and see what they
think
yeah so I went to the library and I got
you a book
S I have to work I'll be listening so I
started trying to do the baby steps so I
already had because I have a 300 000
house I have a fifty thousand dollar
school loans and then have 13 000 left
on my car and I have 20 000 in credit
card debt and I've just been I don't
even know like I've just been so
confused on what to do you know I try to
pay like start paying a lot of the money
because I think I was on baby step two
or three after you save up your
emergency fund then you
um you start attacking that debt you
know show and pay the lowest one first
right but then I had the money to pay
the lowest one first but I didn't
because I I kept looking at my savings
I'm like um I don't know what if I don't
have work how am I gonna you got nervous
you had money in the bank but you went I
don't feel good having only a thousand
bucks in the bank
yes um and it doesn't come from nothing
because I um I was in the Army and then
when I went I doubt I kind of get a
um I
I was really really depressed and I
tried to analyze myself but I also had a
like a drinking problem so I ended up
not working for a whole year doing rehab
and also going like being in an
institution for like psychiatrists and
because I had a savings that year I
ended up paying all my bills to you know
my savings but now I managed to build up
money again and I'm just I don't know
what to do I'm still confused how to go
about this debt and now that I'm sober I
have a clear mind again I'm taking my
antidepressant now these bills are just
holding me back I'm so sad like you know
dragging me behind and I really just
don't want to be in the situation again
so Odette
can I just stop for a second George is
going to walk you through the math of
all of this God tell you how proud of
you I am
you you are incredible
thank you and George and I have to talk
to people I I mean we have the honor of
sitting with people who are struggling
and going through hell you've been to
Hell and you're back
and that's a hard journey
yeah you're an overcomer and if you can
overcome what you went through you can
overcome a pile of debt so how how long
have you been sober
um since 20 uh for two and a half years
now ah it's incredible what's your
official diagnostic what do you what are
you taking meds for
major major depressive disorder and um
anxiety
um are you still uh also had a drinking
problem are you still in treatment for
the MDD
um no I did after
getting out of the site board I did uh
outpatient therapy and then I went into
drug and alcohol counseling for six
months okay and then now um then I got a
job again so I started catching up on
bills and stuff but I also admit that I
do have a spending problem I'm not even
gonna lie about that when I do have
money I spend I don't know if you still
have credit cards open
um yes I don't use them since I read
your book I I just kept them at home I
don't take them if you don't use them
and cut them up
okay and that's going to help you curb
this because what happens is you only
have your own money and then you spend
differently and if you run out of money
you go oh my gosh I can't spend anymore
so that's step one is to not go into any
more debt and cutting up the card is
going to help with that
okay so how much money do you have in
savings
really I have 20 000
in the states love it and what's your
income
I mean
20 000 a year amazing okay so just
looking at the math you have 87 000 of
Consumer Debt right
yes you have 20 in the bank so let's say
you went down to one in savings and then
you have your checking account with some
buffer there that would knock out a huge
portion of this debt
okay right then you're down to less than
70 making 120. how quickly could you
have seventy thousand dollars if you
were making 120 000 and you were doing
the debt snowball
under two years
okay yeah right can you find 35 000 a
year right
no do if you do a Cash out refinance I
take back all those nice things I said
about how smart and brave and strong you
are
talk to us is the took you off the ledge
of doing a Cash out refinance because
what it does it just robs future Odette
and keeps Odette in debt longer with her
mortgage you're going backwards with
your house on the Block and you think
you did something and you know this out
of all people that it takes Behavior
change to transform yeah and so Cash out
refinance is zero Behavior change it's a
shortcut that leads to nowhere
okay but when you bust it and you use
that future income and you're gonna sell
everything you're going to use that
savings you're going to feel that
momentum and that's actually you
expending energy to get out of debt and
that's what changes you for the better
so I looked at like my uh like my
mortgage is like 1700 right
um so I looked at all my bills like you
guys said I should do like just to see
where you know and I realized that like
all my bills probably account for like 2
800 to 3 000 a month but I don't know
where the other money is going well
that's what happens when you start
paying attention by doing a budget and
I'm gonna help you out with that by
giving you one year of every dollar plus
and that has a paycheck planning tool in
there so what you're going to do is put
in your income put in all your bills put
in the due dates and it will actually
show you when you're going to run out of
money and so what happens is when you
make this budget with every dollar it's
the boss you're the boss of it while you
make it and then it becomes the boss of
you for the rest of the month telling
you where and when you can spend money
so hang on the line I'm gonna gift you
that as well as one year of Financial
Peace University watch all nine lessons
and it will make you allergic to debt
for the rest of your life and I want you
to call back and do your debt free
scream or come see us in person because
it will be a powerful one that will
impact so many people you're in
inspirational debt stay the course this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsey
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
if you've never experienced smart
conference before let me tell you the
energy in the room is Mayhem
it's absolutely electric it's it's it's
so fun this is Ramsay's biggest event of
the year the event is packed with
inspiration motivation information
laughter jamming we're talking how to
get in control of your money improving
your mental health strengthening your
relationships and building a successful
career so whether you're on baby step
two or baby step seven you're going to
leave on fire and
you're going to be smarter so make your
plans now our next smart conference is
happening in Chicago this fall join all
of us Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Jade warshaw Ken Coleman and me
at smart conference weekend on September
15th and 16th right now our early bird
general admission ticket price is 80
bucks it's 79.79
and we have limited VIP and platinum
tickets so don't wait to get yours those
sell out usually real quick the VIP
ticket includes a meet and greet with
Jade Rachel George Ken and me and I love
getting to meet you all and hear your
stories it's one of my favorite things
in the world go to ramseysolutions.com
events today to get your tickets I'll
see you there I'm pumped for this yeah
it's gonna be fun all right let's get to
the phones the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you want to jump in and ask your
question Martin is up next in Austin
Texas Martin welcome to the show
how you doing guys um I'm about to be
finished with baby step two and I'm just
kind of at a point where I'm uh
sort of lost because uh I don't own a
home and my wife and I his income isn't
that great
okay
tell us more so you're finishing baby
step two you're almost out of debt
completely
yep okay how much more do you have
um
about five grand in uh loans total
awesome and uh I'm almost done with my
truck too so that that's it'll be done
by the end of the year how much have you
paid off so far Martin
uh the truck one was originally 27
000 and it's down to I'm looking at it
right now uh 12. nice good for you man
and what's wrong with your income how
low are we talking
um my wife and I only make about 5600
combined a month
okay and your next goal after baby step
two is to get that three to six months
of expenses do you have that Target
number in mind and how long that will
take
yeah I believe that'll take us
um we'll probably be around there in
less and less slightly less than a year
okay so I don't feel like we're lost we
still have a lot of goal ahead of us we
got to get out of debt we have to get an
emergency fund we gotta begin invest
investing 15 into retirement so where do
you feel like you're lost in the plan
well uh I I currently rent and I know
that a lot of people that call into the
show are all homeowners and uh I don't
know what to do about renting or should
I save up for a house should I continue
renting should I I'm I'm that's where
I'm mostly lost I would rent with my
head held high
I've rented at multiple places when I
had just really great jobs because it
was the smartest thing for me and my
family in that season
yeah and right now the last thing you
and your wife need is y'all are working
to change everything about your life and
you're changing your family tree is to
drop the stress of home ownership home
buying all that it's a mess right now
so don't that's true you can feel like
you are getting behind by renting you
are not you're getting so far ahead by
paying your debts off
you know what you sound to me you sound
tired like y'all got gung-ho and y'all
went racing off into the woods and
you're what your your hands are on your
knees and you're sucking air and you
realize oh man we're about halfway there
yeah I'm just kind of worn out and we
both are yeah
stay the course man Martin I heard you
say everyone else they're getting homes
have you met everyone
they're broke
yeah that's true and so here's the thing
you've got what's called fomo right now
fear of missing out everyone else is
getting out there's not going to be
homes for Martin when it comes time for
him to buy a house what I want you to
have is something called Jomo that's the
joy of missing out that's the joy of
saying dude I'm running my own race I
don't care what everyone else is doing
on Instagram and it might take me three
years longer to get a house instead of
tomorrow but I'm gonna do it the right
way to where Martin's not calling the
show again a year from now going so we
got a house before we should have and
now that we can't breathe that's a whole
nother version of not breathing and so I
want you to hold your head up high and
go all right we got a six month goal to
get rid of this debt we have another six
months to get the emergency fund then
we're gonna start saving up that down
payment and that means two three years
from now we're gonna have a healthy down
payment and step into this thing the
right way can I tell you something
cheesy that me and my wife did Martin
sure one among many things so I want you
to
wrap your head I was associate dean of a
university my wife was a fancy pants
tenure track research professor
and you know what we did together with
my two-year-old son at the time
we got a construction paper
and some we got some construction paper
and some scissors and we made one of
those chains that you make when you're a
kid and you're going on a ski trip and
you you take off a link every day until
the ski trip or until Christmas
and we made one for every month and we
wrote the dollar amount inside of the
chain and I hung it in our bedroom on
the wall
it matched nothing and it was
embarrassing and I was able to see it
every day this is why we're doing this
and when we every month rolled around
and we got paid once a month we would
send another huge chunk of money towards
to pay off our debt and I we would pull
it off together we let my son pull it
off and we did it as a family but we got
to see it and it just for whatever
reason having 36 chain links for you or
having 72 and taking one off every two
weeks you're gonna get to see that
progress right in front of you and for
whatever reason there's something about
that visual cue that just reminds us
we're in it we're in it we're in it and
we can keep going because there's the
finish line
yeah that makes sense uh I guess what
bothers me is I'm we're currently paying
1400 a month for rent and it'd just be
nice to uh
you know live somewhere where I'm not
making a payment on something well
you're always gonna I mean here's the
thing there's a fallacy out there that
renting is throwing money away right or
you're not putting into the asset and
the truth is renting is the most you'll
ever pay
now mortgage is the least you'll ever
pay
your property taxes can go up your
homeowner's insurance can go up you're
paying a huge chunk of interest to the
lender just for fun to own that house
and that's not touching PMI which most
people have when they get into a house
when they're broke because they can't
put down 20 so you're paying an extra
few hundred bucks to the lender every
month and then there's other things
there's HOA fees uh you got to pay for
all the maintenance and repairs and so
home ownership is the most expensive
thing you'll ever get into and so don't
think for a second that they're just
trading that for a fourteen hundred
dollar mortgage payment would solve all
your problems and you gotta get this out
of your head my brother this idea that
um sure would be nice
because sure would be nice you can have
yourself a nice Jet and then somebody
pull up next to you in their Jet and you
think well it sure would be nice if I
had sure would be nice is a rocket ship
to being broke get out of that game
unplug from that game brother
um sure would be nice to have no
payments that's not where you are right
now so spinning any sort of mental
energy on sure would be nice is a
distraction from where you currently are
you said you had a low income and I'm
doing the math I'm going 5600 a month
take-home pay that's 67 000 a year yeah
that means they're bringing home they're
they're making gross income of 80 plus
and so I don't buy this thing of like oh
we have a low income so we just can't
that's ER syndrome all right now I know
Austin Texas it's expensive out there
it's kind of like Nashville's sister
city and it's pricey but there's people
who are making 40 000 going oh my gosh
if I could make 67 I would be my mind
would be blown the things I could do and
as soon as you get rid of these payments
you're gonna free up that wealth
building tool called your income and
you're going to realize oh we we made
plenty it was just going out to the
wrong things instead of helping us build
wealth and accomplish our goals just
stay on the path stay on the path man
slow and steady slow and steady it's so
hard John and I feel for Martin because
I remember feeling that way when you see
everyone around you
going way further than you are and
you're like but I'm moving so much
slower do I have to do this plan the
problem is shortcuts make you think
you've gone further when really it's
just holding you back
so that's such a tough thing to Grapple
with and go I'm gonna have that Jomo
instead of the fomo I'm gonna do it the
slow way I'm gonna be the tortoise
instead of the hair I'm gonna be the
crock pot instead of the microwave but
man there is such peace in doing it the
slow way and the hairs they're gonna get
caught eventually
whether now or later on and nobody
Cooks good food in the microwave that's
living like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by my good friend Dr
John deloney this hour and we're taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Henry joins us in
Chesapeake Virginia coming up next Henry
what's going on
hey Ramsey team thank you for taking my
call absolutely what's going on
so I recently completed your foundations
in personal finance homeschool
curriculum and I have a question about
Investments okay hit me how old are you
so I'm 16. don't hit George it's a whole
thing I'll go down easy yeah
all right so specifically my question is
Pokemon cards my parents say that
Pokemon cards don't have any value in
them and that they won't make me any
money but it seems like every Pokemon
card set from previous years has just
been going up and up in price
for example a box of Pokemon cards that
were released in 2021 originally sold
for 120 now they sell for about 400.
what are your thoughts and our Pokemon
cards good or not good Investments
great question very well worded Henry
and I'm proud of you for going through
the curriculum did you learn anything in
the curriculum about investing do you
remember anything from that section I
learned that I should never invest in
anything that I do not know about that's
good you seem to know a lot about
Pokemon cards that's for sure
will you teach me something about
Pokemon that I don't know and this will
be even that was a challenge because
John knows everything
I have I
I don't know what Pokemon is so tell me
[Music]
in Japan and its original name is Pocket
Monsters And it used to be or it first
used to be a game on the Game Boy Called
Pokemon Red and Blue
you're like a Pokemon scholar
this is amazing
so and eventually it kind of evolved
into Pokemon cards which came out in
Japan about 1997 and in America about
1999.
this is what I grew up playing John was
Game Boy Pokemon got the cards with my
friends and you got the packs for you
know four or five bucks
dating and uh did you though I'm just I
don't know sure
okay all right so George is going to
teach us so the thing Henry is
there's a lot of Collectibles out there
and people can make money and you
probably have seen YouTubers like Logan
Paul who are like I paid five million
dollars for this super rare Charizard
right that's the stuff that we see that
we click on that we view the reality is
most people it's like going to Vegas
it's like the slot machine you're hoping
that you get the pack with the right
card and all of a sudden you went I
spent 300 bucks and my cars aren't worth
nothing
mm-hmm and so the chances of you getting
that card that you can then flip and
make a whole bunch of money isn't worth
the time now if you wanted to do this
beyond your normal Investments with just
your fun money and you're super into it
you could do it
and I bet you would call back and you'd
be like hey I have seven million dollars
because I invested in Pokemon cards and
we'd all be like what this kid's crazy
and so I'm not saying that it can't be
done I don't want to shoot down your
dreams but the truth is these
Collectibles these Commodities they're
just based on hype and so pokemania
could end next year all of a sudden
because we all move on to something else
versus something like the stock market
Which history has shown us will
appreciate over time yes there'll be
some volatility but over 50 years it's
going to be a good investment we just
don't know that about Pokemon cards
now here's my challenge to your parents
I think they're right I think George is
right
they're not great investment vehicles
and also
sometimes having a collectible that
you're interested in is fun and you
clearly have a lot of it you know the
history of Pokemon cards so is is
trading cards getting new cards going
through the value of them is that fun
for you is that exciting
well it's exciting to open Pokemon card
packs and see that these are pretty rare
from the sets that they were released
and going well this is like one of the
rarest cards in the set
yeah so I
I don't want you to lose that joy for
something that you're interested in that
you think is fun
I just don't want you to go into debt
for it and I want you to not save up for
college for it
but man I want you to enjoy your life
too
all right and something's it's about the
spirit of it right George yeah there's
an entrepreneurial spirit that you have
Henry where you go I love something but
I also want to see like could I make
money from this and that's a great thing
to feel inside you just want to do it
the right way otherwise you're going to
be chasing the next kind of get rich
quick thing I'm going to buy this and
hope because it's the same spirit that a
lot of the crypto Bros have right you
know about cryptocurrency and they're
going oh if we just get this one coin
it's going to be worth 10x a year from
now this is going to be the one and so
you're kind of hoping for the same thing
with Pokemon cards that if I just buy
the right pack it's going to have the
right collectible that one day will be
worth something so I would do it because
you love it and do it with your extra
fun money but I would not do it as part
of your investing strategy
and George let me I'm gonna ask you
about this or tell you about this I
this is 10 12 years ago I had just
bought a house and then somebody else
bought a house down the street and I was
checking every house purchase to see
what they were buying theirs for and I
was kind of doing my own comps in my
house because I was a little bit
and I was trying to keep up with every
sale and what are you listing it for and
I was talking to a finance buddy and he
said something that was important for me
he said because I was telling him hey I
think I'm gonna sell now because it's
gone up this much in three months I'm
gonna do this move and he said hey and
here's the line he gave me he said give
your wife a home
he said you're gonna make money on your
house over time probably maybe not but
probably
but man if you Roi every single
transaction in your life you're gonna
make yourself nuts and it was a call
back to have a place where you can drop
your shoulders like a home right follow
good money principles obviously but we
can get obsessed about things and so I
used to buy a guitar and then I would
always like how much does it cost how
much does it cost and have I made any
money now I buy a guitar because I like
it and I want to play it and I have a
scenario in my head where I'm going to
play it live and if one day it's worth
money great but I had the money now I
saved up the money I bought it I like it
I play it
and if it loses money I still got the
enjoyment out of it that I wanted right
and so I think with things like Pokemon
cards with some baseball cards whatever
thing you're kind of into
have a spirit of Joy about it and if it
goes down in value you still got you
still have the joy but man there's just
I think there's a few things I think we
over Roi everything in our culture and
we over hack everything and there's some
things like oh there's some things like
strumming a guitar in your basement when
your kids are asleep there's something
about I don't know writing in your
favorite Journal that are things that
just bring you peace and they bring you
Joy and they bring you beauty Beauty to
your life man those those are worth the
expenditure in and of themselves and if
they end up being worth money on the
road great right yeah you make a great
Point there's a lot of things in our
lives that we subconsciously make Idols
in our lives where we spend so much time
in it around it that it takes over our
brain and so when crypto came about my
major issue with crypto was not that
you're going to lose a bunch of money
that's a possibility my issue with
crypto was that it was 24 7 and you can
just see on your app at volatility all
day long and there was so many it was
new coins there was Community groups all
about it and you could just have it
consume your life and that's why I joke
that crypto is just you know Mary Kay
for young men because there was this
obsessive nature just like there is with
multiple multi-level marketing where
people were just it took over their life
it became a personality trait and that's
where I go let's draw a line here it's
great to enjoy something it's not great
to be consumed by it that turns into an
addiction I love that that's good there
are some wisdom for you John but I don't
wanna I don't want to hurt Henry's
dreams because I this kid's amazing he's
going to go big places and there's
nothing wrong with using these Pokemon
cards and having fun with it well and I
I also think that's an important
conversation to have with parents
um
so my son uh he cleans out the horse
stalls of the the people who live next
to us on on the ranch next to us
and he earns his own money and he also
mows our yard and I pay him
um for helping participate in in mowing
our place and he earns his own money and
then he'll want to spend it on something
and my first impulse is off often that's
stupid or why would you want to spend it
and then I think no he's 13. this is
when he's going to learn those lessons
of value and what's important and what's
not important so we're taking care of
the giving we're taking care of the
saving
it's your money right and I think for
parents it's good to teach them lessons
but also let him learn oh I spent 25 on
what right and man that wasn't worth it
yeah and learning that way is much
healthier than being forced to never get
to play a video game your whole life or
Never Getting to buy some Pokemon cards
so I'm rooting for you Henry keep us
posted on how it goes my friend this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell host of The George Campbell
YouTube channel you can go check that
out we got three episodes a week Monday
Wednesday Friday launching over there
and my friend Dr John deloney's got a
show that he records next door called
the Dr John deloney show and John you
guys are releasing episodes a few times
a week as well right yep Monday
Wednesday Friday coming up we're on the
same schedule
compare notes to see who's winning our
shows are very different your show is
more long-form calls talking about
mental health relationships boundaries
all the things physical health mine is
just
fun humor personal finance got some
great lessons in hacks in it it it yours
teaches you
just how stacked the system is against
you you know how the entire machine is
is set up for you to fail my job is to
go hey you're in The Matrix and they go
no I'm not am I gonna yeah you are
here's why and they go oh no I'm in The
Matrix help me get out and then they
call my show and John helps me get out
of that there you go oh I love it okay
uh John it's time for a question of the
day which is sponsored by our friends at
neighborly your hub for Home Services
after fires or floods their rainbow
restoration Pros offer homeowners
trusted full-service restoration
expertise like mold remediation carpet
cleaning odor removal and more visit
neighborly.com today to find rainbow
restoration services in your area
today's question comes from Jen in Ohio
Jen writes my husband and I have
followed the baby steps for about six
years paid off a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in debt and we're on
baby step six until a few days ago
Murphy hit her house hard in the form of
a cancer diagnosis that we're paying
mostly out of pocket for the treatment
the wind literally blew our backyard
fence down and then we're paying a
stupid tax because we didn't know our
new state had city taxes and we never
filed them
luckily we have an emergency fund and
can cash flow all of this but this is
the third time something like this has
happened
we feel like we're finally getting ahead
and then we get knocked back enough to
start over how do people stay encouraged
when we feel like we're filing in the
same pit every few years falling in the
same pit every few years and have to
keep pivoting back to gazelle intensity
it's very frustrating and very
discouraging hmm
well there's a lot going on here
obviously the cancer diagnosis sticks
out as something that no one could ever
prepare themselves for regardless of a
financial emergency fund it's great that
you guys have those things but that is a
heavy burden on top of the ankle biters
oh you got to replace the fence we got
to pay the taxes on top of feeling this
emotional weight of oh my gosh we have a
health scare well sometimes it's a fence
is not an ankle biter right it could be
twenty thousand bucks yeah it's almost
the axis of of evil here you've got a
medical challenge a weather challenge in
the government
it's the trifecta the trifecta of
sadness
I wish you were here I'd give you a hug
um so here's my first thought as I'm
reading this
and George you can tell me if I'm
delusional but as I read and wanted to
say that for a while as I read Jen Jen's
story here I kept thinking thank god
um
thank God they continue to get back up
and thank God they continue to save
money put money away pay off their debt
thank God they continue to follow these
steps
because they keep getting shoved and hit
and pushed and they've never had to go
back into debt these things have these
any one of these things a backyard fence
I remember when my fence fell down and I
couldn't afford to put it back up
cancer diagnosis taxes coming out of the
woodwork I've got people that I know who
have been paralyzed for years by back
taxes
and this hurt it was it was a punch in
the nose but it didn't knock them down
because they had continued to put in the
work and so while I I imagine I can't
imagine being in this because I know how
it would feel as an outsider I'm looking
at this going y'all are incredible
you've done the work for just this
moment right yeah and I I love what you
said I wrote down the word perspective
so if you just have some perspective and
go can you imagine if we didn't have
this emergency fund can you just imagine
if we didn't have good health insurance
if we still had 110 Grand but we had a
Suburban in the driveway and so yes this
stinks but what you're looking at here
is you turn to crisis into an
inconvenience by having the emergency
fund which is exactly what it's there
for so yes it hurts because you got to
rebuild the emergency fund and you're
tired and you're dealing with this
health diagnosis but also we can just
get back up we're not in debt we're not
moving backwards it's just a pause
and there's no way life is going to
continue to throw thing after things so
it's easy to think in your mind John
when things like this happen life is
always going to be this way there's
always going to be another thing holding
us back why even try let's just go into
debt and just live our life but you got
to get back up yeah it reminds me of
um the other day uh when we were in the
dressing room we were had some photo
shoot stuff and I just happened to see
George across your lower back
um your tattoo of one of your favorite
bands Chumbawamba and that was a private
moment John it was but as you're always
walking around
um bestowing Upon Us great Chumbawamba
lyrics you get knocked down and you get
back up again
you're never going to bring me down
never yeah wow
the inspiration would come from John
deloney and Chumbawamba today it's your
turn man I don't actually have that
tattoo it was a temporary tattoo it's it
it's it was absolutely not it was
actually inside of a large Aztec Sun the
whole thing is a little bit
uncomfortable but it's cool
um listen our hearts are with you this
like I I don't want to make a light of
this like
y'all are in it y'all are in it y'all
are in it cancer house stuff government
stuff
I just want you to back up two or three
steps and be so proud of yourselves
this is why we do this show
because life is coming at you the
world's coming at you punches are thrown
kicks are thrown and most people have to
fold up because they haven't done the
hard work so grieve this be sad about it
be really pissed off about it all that's
good all that's right all that's normal
and then get back up on the path and go
again
because really what's the other option
right what's the other option but to get
back up and get going again good word
thanks for the question Jen all right
let's take a quick one here from Katie
in Pittsburgh Katie what's going on
George hi John thanks for taking
particular sure how can we help
around intensity I should be bringing
into baby stick baby step six and would
just like your advice on how to balance
investing outside of retirement and
paying off my home early okay
um so so some quick background on my
situation I bought my house in 2020
before following the baby steps on a
30-year fixed rate I just paid off over
120 000 in student loan debt earlier
this year
that's amazing thank you thank you
um I have my emergency fund fully funded
and I started back up my investment in
my Roth K so I'm planning now to adjust
my mortgage payment so the amount would
allow me to pay off in 12 years so now
it would be a 15-year mortgage I still
have a little bit left after my expenses
and I'm just wondering should I be
paying more towards my mortgage should I
be setting that aside to invest in
mutual funds eventually what would you
do in my situation I'll tell you what I
would do and I'll tell you what I'd did
I would keep investing 15 into that Roth
401k and any money beyond that I would
start throwing at the house I would not
put extra money on top of that into
mutual funds outside of retirement until
you pay it off
because your next focus is getting a
paid for house so that you have freed up
your greatest wealth building tool your
income and then you're at baby step
seven where you build wealth and you
give outrageously and if you want to
invest 25 30 40 you can do that
but you seem young how old are you
I'm 32. okay you got plenty of time what
do you do for a living
I work for an insurance company so you
had a good year last year
I did yes
what do you make
I make 130 000 a year amazing is that
salary or Commission
salary
what opportunities do you have to
increase that over the next couple of
years
have you maxed yourself out or are you
just getting started
um I actually
um I'm I think I should have be
expecting additional
um salary increase later this year and
then I'm already bonus eligible for next
year I knew it you know how you do it
because you paid off 120 something
thousand bucks in a year and you're a
gangster like that all of that new money
pay off your house I want you to take
that 12-year plan and pull it down to
six pull it down to seven get rid of
that stupid thing and then you're gonna
be free it's gonna be awesome that's a
great plan I love focusing on one thing
at a time and that mortgage is in your
sights nothing can stop you and Katie's
gonna get there way faster than she even
thinks that puts this hour of the Ramsay
show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Dr John Maloney all the folks in
the booth and you America thanks for
listening we'll be back real soon
John deloney if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsay baby
steps go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the get started button will
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
that's ramsesolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by my friend Dr
John deloney best-selling author and uh
just an all-around good guy great
husband great dad and I'm being paid to
say all of this and we are taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you want to jump in
we'll talk about whatever you want to
talk about this is your show which means
if it's bad it's your fault not right it
could be your fault that's true but Hey
listen
um
if you are like most people and you're
scared of how our country deals with
money and you're watching the debt
ceiling fights and you're listening to
the stats about credit cards about to
cross the trillion dollar threshold and
mortgage to all that and you just wish
hey I wish people were listening to this
show I wish people could get some of the
empowerment and not be told this is the
only way to do this and you're a slave
to the system
here's a no cost it doesn't cost you
anything way of getting this information
into the hands of your neighbors of the
people who vote the wrong way according
to you people that you disagree with
people that you love the easiest best
way to do that is simply subscribe to
the show
like it thumbs up it whatever you got to
do on your device however you're
consuming this whether you're watching
us on YouTube you're listening to us on
podcasts listen to us on the radio
give us a thumbs up leave a five star
review
subscribe to the show it kicks it up in
the algorithms and it simply puts the
show in front of more people
we don't need any more pats on the back
George makes us do that for him all the
time we're always telling George how
great is but you can really help out
your neighbor and you can help out
people who are struggling by just doing
something as simple as hitting subscribe
so please take a second and do that for
for all of us
um and man George I'm hoping that
as we're sitting in this crisis and this
mess and crisis after Christ after
crisis at some point a huge swath of
this country will say enough
enough I think we're getting there
people are getting sick and tired of
being sick and tired and I hope we can
intersect their life with some truth and
some hope and go it doesn't have to be
this doesn't have to be like this and
that's a great place to get to so we're
grateful to be here grateful you're
listening Scott kicks us off this hour
in Austin Texas Scott welcome to the
show
hey thank you so much I appreciate y'all
taking a call absolutely how can we help
so the biggest issue I'm having is uh my
wife and I are having a hard time
aligning on budget categories and
following through on it
um we've been through Dave Ramsey a few
times and I'm kind of more of the strict
one on it and she's not not 100 with it
so we're having a hard time I guess it
matters is it a certain category what's
the argument here yeah you well hold on
you put in two you put in two very
different challenges one is we're having
trouble aligning together uniting around
our Who We Are
the other one is we're just not doing it
and you you kindly and graciously said I
am she's not so what's the bigger
challenge here the trying to come up
with the right categories you want a
little more in savings she wants some in
food you want some in clothes or is the
harder thing you all agree on this
budget you high five each other
um you'll weep and pray and sing old
white snake covers together y'all Bond
and unite and then she goes off and just
spins whatever she's gonna spend
yeah so we will get together and have
our meeting and agree on it but I feel
like when we do have it she hasn't
really
looked or it doesn't really uh so Tracy
agrees on it but then we go back in this
blow over each time myself included in
some areas why do y'all disrespect each
other in that way
that's a good question so
well I guess the backstory we've been
married for about 20 years and for the
first half or three quarters of our
marriage I was just blown it financially
she was handling everything so I was
continuously just kind of spending over
what we had and she was trying to manage
it now the tables are kind of turned and
I'm doing the finances
and I feel like uh she thought she told
me a few times that hey you know this is
what you did for 15 years so
so I think a little bit of the issues
doesn't kind of trust me
um with my track record which I totally
so is that kind of a boy who cried wolf
like oh look at Scott over here telling
me he's gonna stick to the budget look
at this is it kind of there have you sat
down with her and told her told her what
you just told us like hey I screwed up
I'm sorry instead of kind of a place of
Tit for Tat I'm gonna get at you because
you gotta me you know what's the spirit
of these conversations been
yeah so we it's good we have talked
about that I think she's still
um
she said yeah I get it but I think she's
still kind of
not uh
I won't I won't say over it but yeah I
can tell it's still irritating her that
are there things about your your former
life Scott
that still show up
in the modern times they just have a
different a different gloss on them
meaning maybe you drank a lot when y'all
first got married and she did not like
how you're a little bit out of control
she didn't know if you were going to
show up on time and now you never drink
but you're kind of having an affair with
your job and you work 90 hours a week
the pathology is is the same but the
action's a little bit different and a
lot of times when we try to solve Vision
issues with just a plan and not an
identity change
our behaviors might be a little bit
different but that machine that's
running underneath everything is still
going
and so if you're just a guy with another
scheme and another plan and another this
and another that man she's gonna feel
that and smell that a mile away so
she'll go along with it ma'am she's just
gonna spin what she's gonna spin
because you're not you're still the same
guy you just wrapped it up in a
different suit what George was saying is
profound and I don't want to miss that
there's a difference between saying hey
I screwed up so I got this new plan for
us
there's there's that Avenue and it
almost never works
you doing the money versus her doing the
money y'all doing the same thing you
just flipped you just flip the other
side of the barbell there's something
different about saying hey let's go out
for a weekend
what we're doing is not working and I
started this
and so as the guy that that blew you off
for 15 years I need you to hear me say
from my core I'm sorry I let you down I
let me down and I let future us down
and we're starting to fall right back
into that same thing and I don't want to
do it will you plan a new life for us
together and what are the things that I
bring to the table that make you cringe
that make you not believe me
and then give her an opportunity to say
to ask you that same question and now
we're uniting around who we are and
where we want to go and then a plan laid
on top of that man it's gonna work every
time but if a football coach calls a
play
and a couple of the people on the field
only care about themselves and their
stats and their numbers and some other
guys just care about knocking the guy
down in front of them and then a couple
of guys care about running the play
Everything's Gonna Fall Apart
so you've got to have that core identity
does that make sense
that makes total sense you just more
backstory I definitely have a background
of addiction to different areas I've
been you know cleaning those up quote
over the years but so you've got a wife
who's scared
let's start with identity and let's
start with I'm sorry and let's start
with forgiveness and let's start with
let's get on the same page of where
we're headed together and then we're
going to put the Ramsey plan on top of
that and there will be no stopping y'all
compromise my friend Grace and
accountability those are the keys to
doing a budget together
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show it's a show
about you and it's a show about living a
life of debt Freedom going against the
grain living counter culturally bucking
the system taking control of your mental
health your relationships your career
your money and realizing that it's not
up to someone else
it's not up to the government it's not
up to your brother-in-law or your uncle
or your parents or your trauma that you
can overcome and you can move forward
and so if you want to be a part of that
you can call into the show at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney this hour and uh Dr John I
thought it'll be fun to play a little
clip of a celebrity you know time to
time we like to play some celebrity
clips that have to do with money and
usually like it's not always a good kind
of clip but this one tickled me in a
wonderful way and I thought you might
enjoy it too would you indulge me
if if you want to be tickled in a
wonderful way I'm happy to indulge let's
roll that beautiful Bean footage
oh we lost yeah that's too much I'm like
you want it we're gonna try it one more
time mother go pick a house you know
she's still one of them old school baby
that's too much I'm like you want it
and like it feels good to just tell them
yeah give me that without what I'll do
what I know checking credit or none of
that like the ladies like she was like I
need to check your credit I was like I
beg your pardon
excuse me straight cash yeah straight
okay my mom was like baby don't do that
I was like hold on Mama she disrespected
me hey lady
I want this house and I want the 10-day
closing right now do it
oh okay so for context that is Shaquille
O'Neal talking with uh with some guys
explaining the story of when he went to
buy his mom a house and the lady's like
hey we need to run your credit score if
you want to buy this house and he was
disrespected because Shaq is worth 400
million dollars and so the credit score
is not needed because the guy's playing
paying with cash like he mentioned and
there was uh the uh the further back
story is his sister had just passed away
and
it was right during covet or right
before coven he won his family close and
so he said Mom I'll buy you a house once
you come on down and
George like
you know we we had uh calls earlier
today in the segments about hey I've
been doing this I've been doing this and
life keeps happening I think it's
important to tell folks
did you following the Ramsey plan
getting out of debt it does not
inoculate you from bad stuff mom is
still going to get sick you know wife is
still going to step out of your marriage
kids are gonna just have struggles life
is gonna happen what this does is it
gives you options and
um
it just I mean this is a personal story
my cousin passed away suddenly his name
was James he was just an amazing guy
um somebody a cousin that I really loved
and he told me some things privately
over the course of my life that meant a
lot to me and when he passed away this
is seven or eight months ago
my wife and I had the privilege and the
ability to get this
just be really really sad we bought
plane tickets we flew down to see them
um uh went to his funeral I got to stand
at his gasket and we had a couple of
hard conversations I wasn't happy and I
was it was it was sad I was frustrated
but I didn't have to worry about
couldn't we even afford to go to this
thing can we afford to get a hotel when
everyone was like I don't know if we can
go out to eat let's just go out to eat
I'll pick it up a ticket and it's not
because we're super rich or well through
anything but it's because
we had an emergency fund and Shaq at a
much you know elevated situation can
just say I need all my family around me
right now when the world's falling apart
just go pick out a house and I'm gonna
buy the house right so we do this stuff
not because life's not going to happen
but because it's going to happen and it
gives us the ability to just make some
moves and to take care of ourselves to
just experience life to be really joyful
or to really see beauty or to really be
sad because we're not worried about can
I eat can I afford to do this stuff and
I just I just I love that it's such a
cool picture I just it won't happen in
my lifetime but it'd be awesome to be
able to say
mom just I'm buying my next door
neighbor's house just come over so we
gosh what an amazing what an amazing
moment right that's an aspirational goal
and you know it's easy to look at a
video like that and go well who has 400
million dollars so it's easy for him to
just go buy a house in cash for his
whole family listen the idea behind it
is that Shaq said oh you're not going to
disrespect me by saying I got to be a
part of this little maze and system you
guys created I exist outside I opted out
of the system I opted out of the system
and so even if you don't have 400
million dollars you can still pay for a
home with cash that's reasonable people
still do it I even in today's America
and people can buy houses without credit
scores and I tell you that because I did
it and there's a process called manual
underwriting there's a product called a
no score loan and if you just hit a set
of criteria like you know have a very
low debt to income ratio have a pile of
money in the bank have a good down
payment get a 15-year fixed rate you
will get a mortgage with an excellent
interest rate
and when you think about what the credit
score is made up of every single piece
relates to debt right your payment
history how much you owe the length of
your credit history how much new credit
you've taken on what the mix of the
credit is are you getting them hint here
all of this has to do with debt and I
love nothing more than helping people
take off this veil of the system and go
you don't have to play this game is it
slightly more nuanced or the things you
gotta a few Hoops you might have to jump
through sure but way less Hoops than
figuring out how the credit card reward
system works well and
it was when I found out that if somebody
wrote you a check for five million
dollars your credit score doesn't change
that I realized oh that has nothing to
do your net worth your income not a
factor you can be absolutely broke and
have a great credit score it has to do
with your relationship to lenders has
nothing to do with how well you're doing
financially nothing play stupid games
Win stupid prizes and one of those
prizes is I have a great credit score
and no money in the bank and no money in
retirement but I pay my debts perfectly
on time good for you bro I'm playing a
different game and if you want to play
that game go for it if you would have
done that game just watch the news for
30 minutes and look at the anxiety and
depression and default and debt ratios
and that's the game you are opting into
and George the show takes a lot of heat
because
we're not real this we're so out of
touch I can't think of a more empowering
show that says we believe in you the
listener you the person who's been on
the margins you the person who's been
spit on and kicked you the person who's
been through abuse and hell at home we
believe in you so much we think you can
do
something different we don't think that
you are stuck in some sort of have to be
rescued moment no we believe in you we
believe in your family we believe in
your community we believe in your
friends we believe in all of you and
nobody tells you that they tell you
you're broken you're screwed up you're
the worst thing that ever happened to
you and nobody's coming for you so you
just better sit at home and maybe the
government will come no we think more of
you than that we think more of you than
you think of you
and that's why we tell you you can you
can you can but but George like I said
you gotta opt out of the system you got
to play different games absolutely and
one of the ways we help people do that
is through Financial Peace University
that's the thing that did it for me when
I went through it 10 years ago and
what's really cool is that right now all
of the personalities are leading
Financial Peace University themselves
through virtual classes which mean
anyone around the country can join this
and uh John delone is going to be
leading one I'll be leading one and this
is the plan there's nine lessons in here
we're gonna go through it in about four
and a half weeks meeting twice a week
and we unpack how the system is meant to
keep you broke we unpack how it's not
all your fault but it's your
responsibility we unpack how to Buck the
system and take control and get that
Financial Freedom and freedom in all
areas of your life so join us for this
we're going to be your personal
cheerleaders encouragers showing you how
to pay off debt how to build wealth and
you're gonna have a community of
thousands of people joining you as well
hey my class starts on Monday oh this
Monday Monday so you got to join us once
it starts you can't join that's a good
call is that the rule that's the rule if
you don't join mine you're gonna be
stuck in George's class God forbid and
it's over lunch it's over lunch you can
take the class out in the parking lot
during your lunch break let's do this
love it so John's class is on Monday
mine launches June 20th go grab your
spot right now at fpu.com fpu.com is the
place to go it's gonna be a party sign
up hey tell your friends tell your mom
this is all virtual so anyone around the
country can join we'll be meeting for
about an hour each time have an awesome
discussion activities you watch the
videos beforehand and I'm telling you
live q a this four to five weeks could
change everything you look back and go
oh that was it that was the turning
point for me so don't miss it fpu.com
Join one of our virtual Fu classes
coming up real soon
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney this
is the Ramsay show if you want to call
us up it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll talk about your
life and your money Wesley joins us up
next in Atlanta Wesley welcome to the
show
uh thank you all for having me sure
what's going on
um I'm a 20 year old college student uh
my grandmother and my mother passed away
both passed away within the past two
years uh and I've been left with the
mortgage on the house with my older
sister
um how old did you say you were
21. okay
uh I currently have 20 20K in savings
and uh and currently making roughly 41k
a year
um I was calling for advice about the
mortgage
um where do I invest or what to invest
in with no Roth IRA
and then um uh thoughts about uh me on
my first car loan
so I think you need to back up first
tell me about this house can you afford
it
me and my sister are splitting every
knee down the middle and paying on the
mortgage what's the payment on the
mortgage total
uh
uh at least a thousand a month
and so you're splitting that 500 a piece
yes sir okay to what end
uh gonna have a little more detail on
that one
like so you're you and your sister are
going to pay into this house together
and pay it off one day for what is
somebody living there are you living
there is she living there
my sister lives there and that's that's
where I go back home and I go out and
leave school
and it's 50 50 between you and her the
ownership
yes sir
so I'm going to tell you something it's
it's hard to hear okay because I know
there's a lot of
love and memories wrapped into that home
but you're you're putting money into
you're keeping a dream alive let me put
it this way your mom
was doing the best she could and said I
just want to split everything 50 50. but
right now y'all are splitting an asset
50 50.
and I would much rather see you guys
consider selling this house and taking
that equity and your sister take hers
you take yours and then y'all can start
making some decisions that are going to
be best for each other right now moving
forward
versus you putting 500 a month into a
house that your sister lives in that you
don't have and what you're going to do
is you're going to find yourself without
a house in a couple of years or you're
going to find yourself in an apartment
still in a couple years pretty
frustrated that your sister's living in
this you see what I'm saying it's just
gonna it's a recipe for you and your
sister really having some relational
challenges down the road
that's why I asked you to what end
what's the end game here have you talked
to your sister about the long-term plan
yeah we talk about it often what is the
long-term plan
to both own it and then
um in all honesty I'll probably I'll
probably just just give it on to her
since we don't have anywhere else to
live how old is your sister in the
future
uh she's 25.
okay
now you call with a bunch of questions
you're like I got 20 in savings I make
41 000. I've got the mortgage but then
you also said I'm looking at my first
car loan
do you have a car currently
yes sir so this would be upgrading in
car
yes sir okay
why why can't you pay cash for a
reasonable used car
you've done so well so far why go into
debt now
um long-term long-term for the purposes
uh for just I plan on owning a truck
over time and then I wanted that truck
to be the family car so whenever that
happens but I would just going to just
go ahead and get it now and just chip
away at it and then just have it to have
it by the time you have a family you may
go oh this truck's I want a new truck
and so I don't make plans for 10 years
down the line with a car purchase
because it's a depreciating asset so you
have 20 in savings is that your
emergency fund plus some
yes sir okay I would be looking at
getting a very reasonable used truck I'm
talking used because trucks are insanely
expensive right now it's the worst time
in history to buy a truck let me put it
this way I make way more than forty one
thousand dollars a year and my truck is
a 2006 Tundra with almost 200 000 miles
on it and I love it
so if you want to spend cash factoring
in the price of the car the taxes the
maintenance the gas all of that and you
can do it with cash then go for it but
outside of that it sounds like you're
still in school are you cash flowing
school do you have more to pay
no sir I don't have any debt okay so
school is paid for outside of the
mortgage and then once you graduate
what's the plan
possibly professional and there's a
couple big companies in Atlanta that
I've talked to me before and offer me a
job and whenever I get done playing uh
or being an athlete that didn't hire me
okay and uh I also can go into coaching
as well and then you still got this
house situation and so that's what John
was talking about we have to have a game
plan of hey when I'm done with college
and I need to move somewhere I can't
still be paying into this and we may
need to be looking at selling this thing
once I graduate and you take your half I
take my half that becomes Wesley's down
payment and her down payment for a house
in the future is there any reason you
said she wouldn't have a place to live
she's 25 is there any reason why she
isn't working or wouldn't be able to get
herself an apartment just like you have
uh well she wasn't working since she was
taking care of our grandmother while she
was sick and so she wasn't able to work
at all and so now she's just getting
back into working okay all right and I'm
just I'm just trying to make it easier
for her to crawl back out
the world needs more guys with hearts
like you have okay
um you have an incredible heart and
you've you've had an incredible amount
on your shoulders the last few years
trying to stay in school trying to
continue to perform on the athletic
field trying to take care of your mom
and your grandmother's day pass away
trying to care of your sister man you're
a good man
that's why I want you to hear what I'm
saying not as like oh this guy's just it
wouldn't wouldn't fuddy-duty old man he
doesn't understand what I don't want you
to be is 23
and you're paying on last year's truck
you're paying on a home you don't own
you're looking at man I didn't get
drafted like I thought I was going to
and now I've got to figure out what
comes next you can create a mess for
yourself
or you can talk to your sister and say
hey I'm going to pay on this house for
six more months
I'm going to pay on this house for three
more months and then you and I are gonna
have to have a make a hard decision
about are we going to keep this house
with all the joy but also all the pain
inside this place are we going to sell
it we're going to split the equity even
if you want to give her a little bit
more of the equity whatever whatever is
in your heart
but I want the next few years for you
and your sister to be as free as
possible with as few chains wrapped
around your hands and your wrists and
your ankles as possible
and so sometimes that's sitting down and
doing really hard things like selling
the family house like telling your
sister hey I've got to put a boundary on
this thing because I also have to be
smart about where I'm gonna live and
don't count chickens before they hatch
man a lot of businesses talk a lot of oh
yeah when you get done you come talk to
me and man they are a ghost when you
actually pick up the phone and make
those calls so
maybe sitting with your sister and
having a a
George I'm talking about like a
boundaries conversation like a deadline
like this can't go on indefinitely
what if we on September 1 or what if
October 1st we sit down and we figure
out where we are how much money you're
making what job prospects look like for
you how you feel about being in this
house what my prospects are let's just
be honest about where we happen to be
you talk a lot about grieving what was
especially when something traumatic
happens it can be hard to just let go of
something that had such sentimental
value and even Financial value in the
case of a house what is the steps to
take when you know you have a loss in
the family and there's this thing that's
attached to that how do you even grieve
that and move on
I think you got to stop for a second
um and when what what I know about the
the psychology of grief and the
Neurology of grief is we don't often
make great choices which is why you got
to have people in your life around you
um that's why people call the show
because sometimes they find themselves
in a mess and they've got nobody to call
or nobody that they trust right
um having a mentor having a coach having
a counselor having a pastor having some
people who are few years down the road I
would love to see his sister get in a
grief group of people who've lost their
mom who've been caretakers of people who
passed away there's there's groups like
that everywhere where people will walk
alongside you as your body heals and the
fog begins to lift and you begin to ask
that scary terrifying question what am I
going to do next
good wisdom there thanks for the call
Wesley this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from James 1
17. every good thing given and every
perfect gift is from above coming down
from the Father of Lights with whom
there is no variation or shifting shadow
the great Tim Keller who passed away
today at 72 after a battle with
pancreatic cancer
said if you have money power and Status
today it is due to the century and place
in which you were born to your talents
and capacities and health none of which
you earned in short all your resources
are in the end the gift of God
sad to hear the news today John about
one of the greatest Christian thinkers
authors Evangelical Ministers of our
time yeah yeah I can be uh
pretty sarcastic when it comes to some
of the uh
what passes is spiritual wisdom these
days and Tim Keller was one of the
steadfast ones it's a good guy yeah
Decades of impact and Ministry and I'm
currently reading through is the meaning
of marriage book one of his greats so
highly recommend you guys pick that up
and pick up really any of his books so
much wisdom there and thinking of his
family today with the heartbreaking news
of his passing great guy great guy all
right let's go to the phones Chris is up
next in West Virginia Chris welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um I've been in my current job now I
guess about six years I I took it
because good benefits good money uh job
security and everything but now it's
just really uh
boring not very fulfilling and uh
so I'm kind of in a Crossroads here but
I had a acquaintance call me with a job
offer uh in the the thing is that the
job is probably about
um
I don't know five thousand less a year
uh lacking benefits and all the perks
that I enjoy here at my current job
so it's just kind of a hard decision to
make and uh of course my wife is a
little concerned about it and I'm just
trying to decide the best option in what
to do there
often when we find ourselves at what
feels like a Crossroads here
um there's a whole bunch of other rooms
that just don't have the lights turned
on yet
and so
it could be that your friend calling you
kind of wakes you out of a stupor and
says yeah man just the thought of doing
something different doing something new
doing something with a buddy it lights
you up and also that doesn't mean that's
the right thing
it could be all right I'm gonna make a
plan because this job is is slowly
killing me but at the same time I do
like the life that it provides so what
else can I do that might have a similar
provide me and my wife with a similar
life but man it's going to bring me more
joy and so I really want to caution you
against a that either or thinking I'm
trapped and I gotta get out and I gotta
get on the first train out of town the
whole City's coming it's not right it's
not so
um
when you say I'm kind of bored
tell me a little bit more about that
um really the the job is not very
fulfilling I work in education and it's
more or less based on a number of
students and that fluctuates so much
there's days that I go without having
students which means I'm in an office
for eight hours trying to occupy my time
with
um working on certifications or
different things just to pass the time
throughout the day and what is it that
brought you into education in the first
place
uh well I taught through most of my
career in one form or another I was uh
certified instructor and such and then
after retiring from my previous job
kind of took it on just to pass time
that I thought I enjoyed teaching
and stuck with it and then uh it turned
into the fact that it's a great paying
job great benefits
um
and you know it takes care of all the
Necessities so you're I could be way off
here but are you a military veteran
who's working at a university in some
sort of Veteran Affairs role
uh close uh military vet and law
enforcement for 15 years but I do work
for an adult education program okay
you are a teacher and you are a public
servant
right or wrong up or down that is who
you are my brother and so
the world needs two things real bad
public servants and teachers
and so it sounds to me like the world
needs what you are good at and what you
are passionate about it's just about
finding the right place to do that and
there is no shortage of those places
so what makes this next job the Saving
Grace that's going to be the ticket out
what is it about it that draws you to it
and security but as uh operations
manager for a small company so it's
active
it's moving and getting around and
um
is there a potential that you could be
bored on some days
um
not likely My worry is that Chris goes
with Chris and so if the solution you
know is Chris needs to figure out what's
going on inside him that's going man I'm
just dragging I need a challenge now it
could be the job but it could also be
we've got some stuff to deal with deeper
so
my wife told me one time I was talking
about how I
wanted to take this other job but I
really liked where I was and she said
something that was really important
she said I'm watching this job kill my
husband
and I'm willing to take whatever Avenue
is going to get you from this
and so you mentioned that your wife is
really kind of tied to the benefits and
the perks and the cool stuff
is and this is true across the board so
I is she
more interested in the perks
then she is her husband coming home
joyful and happy and excited about the
day he just had or you shoot him you see
what I'm getting at I don't talk about
about your wife but also there's a
reality no no no no no no she she agrees
uh you know she she wants me to be happy
what I'm doing we've we've talked about
it uh we're maybe step three uh
financially uh we're doing well uh we
paid off everything except for the
mortgage and uh the money that I make of
the job is what we're setting to the
side so her job covers the bills so if I
took a a hit in the pay Department it
wouldn't hurt that bad but the concern I
guess for both of us is retirement I'm
54 she's 44. uh so we're just now
getting the point of uh starting to put
15 back for retirement starting next
month
um so it's just more or less the the
benefits package are there no retirement
options with the new gig
no it's
um just a small business uh maybe in the
future
um but right now no it's just pretty
much powering a car that part is
worrisome the fact that there's no
option for retirement with this new gig
and you want to retire in the next 10
years probably so that might be
something where you go I need to switch
jobs this ain't it I appreciate you
friend for bringing this to my attention
I'm going to keep looking for something
that has benefits because that's what we
need as a family right now and I sound
like a broken record here because I feel
like I say this on my show all the time
I say this on this show of course all
the time
I would love to see you and your wife go
for a weekend retreat together y'all are
busting your butt y'all working hard
and plan have the fun it is it can be so
fun
but plan where do we want to be I turned
65 which is basically a thousand right I
turned 65 in 10 years
um where do we want to be and then it
can be about dreaming and about where we
want to live and what do we want our
life to look like and here's a fun
exercise what do you want the house to
feel like when you get home and what do
you want the house to feel like when I
get home
and then we're going to reverse engineer
how do we build that world and there's a
mathematical component here's how much
money I got to make so I might have to
stay in this job that I'm kind of slowly
dying in for two more years so that we
can get this far ahead or I'm going to
stay in this job but I'm gonna start
looking for opportunities to get out at
X salary and X benefit package but it
gives you a guiding map and it's
something that y'all build together so
man go do this together plan ahead be
very specific
and then I'm telling you man you're a
hard worker the job will show up when
you know where you're headed thanks for
the call Chris that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books my thanks
to my co-host Dr John baloney all the
folks in the booth and you America until
next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]